[Applaudissements]
vous allez faire quelque chose qu'on
avait déjà fait dans cette émission vous
voulez le faire dans une valise encore
plus petites sont tombés n'aura va
rentrer dans la valise au maroc dit vous
pouvez venir vous allez voir s'est
réalisée sans trucage pour entrer que tu
fus c'est chaud c'est pas grave on
tâchera et doivent rentrer dans cette
sphère professionnelle pour vous avez
vous mêmes termes et la bâtisse thomas
mérogis toile adam va la tuer il ya de
l'eau zahia maintien il y avait 500 mais
oui elle encore plus petite toutefois si
j'étais vous je retrouverai la voilà
attention il faut souligner les tuer
l'enfant
non vraiment le stopper on n'a pas
besoin de musique là ça fait beaucoup
ainsi alors voilà donc la personne va
rentrer à beaumont tissu tu veux pas
qu'à mieux je suis meilleur que messi
j'ai beau catch up
méfie toi de lui mais cei s'est fait
trop tard révèle il l'a fait déjà trop
tard alors il aura fermé arriver là les
cheveux sur riblon et donc on range les
chinois comment vous sentez une qu'elle
va zy baba mais tu vas pas fermé six
rites les sanglants je suis obligé parce
que je partais en vacances dès ce soir
là dessus et non il ne rate mais n'aura
ça va non je parte sinon à s'assurer des
débouchés cheminée je fais déjà ça et
veut s'y résoudre il ya des peuples et
des deux là c'est dégueulasse ça fait
vraiment le meilleur mais serial killer
mon pote les experts et n'aura t elle
adore le faire c'est surtout vrai mais
les chômeurs pas l'encourager
mais c'est une somme c'est une demande
de la personne a tenté d'asseoir sur la
balle et 10 m'en foutisme et n'aura bien
sûr ah ça fait bizarre
juste à ne pas refaire à la maison et
nova ves est sûre nous voulons le faire
je me sens belle oui tu vois que je lui
dois
il devrait être calme et voilà qu'ils
fermaient menora combien eloi les ébats
et nora vous fermez est fermé elle évite
la pire à la fois la tuile et vous prie
les gars c'est que pour elle ça sa f3
[Rires]
est non alors atteint la mi mai est le
radical desquels ouais c'est vrai on
doit ce cas c'est nous on l'a entre 4 et
de rage tout vous étendez oui oui
qu'est-ce qui vaut lui
mais elle aura bravo bravo
alors à vous les jeudis cette petite
valise ça nous fait toujours du bien
moi j'aime bien tu fais vraiment dast pa
tu dois faire des tubes même plus aux
soirées valises toi tu fais des soirées
valises non oui c'est ça